IN AN AREA
WHERE BATHROOMS ARE SCARCE,
BILLY'S HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ATTRACT
A SLEW OF BATHROOM-GOERS
THAT CAN THEN BE CONVERTED
TO CUSTOMERS.
ONCE THEY USE THE BATHROOM,
THEN WE SELL THEM
ON EATING HERE.
- MM-HMM.
- YOU GUYS COULD BECOME
THE NEIGHBORHOOD TOILET.
- YEAH, I GUESS
IT'S GOOD IDEA.
- AND WHERE BETTER TO MARKET
TO THEM
THAN WHERE WE HAVE THEIR
COMPLETE, UNDIVIDED ATTENTION?
WE PUT TOGETHER
A SHORT COMMERCIAL
FEATURING GLORIA,
AND ONCE IT WAS DONE,
I INSTALLED
MOTION-ACTIVATED MONITORS
IN EVERY BATHROOM STALL
AND URINAL AT BILLY'S.
WITH THE AD IN PLACE,
IT WAS TIME
TO START SPREADING THE WORD
THAT BILLY'S BATHROOMS
WERE FOR EVERYONE.
THE WINDOW SIGNS WOULD WORK
GREAT FOR PASSERS-BY,
BUT I ALSO WANTED
TO SPREAD AWARENESS
TO OTHER BUSINESSES
IN THE AREA.
SO IF YOU HAVE ANY CUSTOMERS
THAT NEED TO USE THE BATHROOM,
YOU CAN SEND THEM
TO BILLY'S DOWN THE BLOCK.
- OH, OKAY.
- NOW I WAS READY
TO CONVINCE PEOPLE
WHO CAME FOR THE BATHROOM
TO STAY FOR THE FOOD.
HI, THERE.
ARE YOU HERE
TO USE THE BATHROOM?
OH, TO EAT? OKAY.
- YEAH.
- ARE YOU HERE
TO USE THE BATHROOM?
HERE TO EAT.
THREE?
- YES.
- FOR THE BATHROOM
OR FOR A TABLE?
OKAY, UM, YEAH,
SHE CAN HELP YOU.
AT FIRST, IT WAS LOOKING
LIKE MY SIGNS WEREN'T WORKING,
BUT THEN THE BATHROOM CROWD
STARTED TO ARRIVE.
HI.
FOR THE RESTROOM?
- YEAH.
YES, IT'S RIGHT AT THE BACK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
- OKAY.
- THEY WERE ABOUT TO SEE
OUR COMMERCIAL,
AND I WANTED TO SHOW GLORIA
THEIR REACTIONS.
SO IT'S NOT ENTIRELY LEGAL,
BUT WE SET UP
A COUPLE HIDDEN CAMERAS
INSIDE THE BATHROOM.
I'LL JUST NEED TO GET PEOPLE
TO SIGN A RELEASE
CONSENTING TO THE USE
OF THE FOOTAGE
ONCE THEY GET OUT,
WHICH I DON'T FORESEE
BEING AN ISSUE.
- HELLO, HOW ARE YOU?
WELCOME TO BILLY'S.
PLEASE ENJOY THIS MESSAGE.
[upbeat rock music]
- YOU MAY NOT BE A CUSTOMER,
BUT AT BILLY'S,
YOU'RE STILL WELCOME
TO USE THE BATHROOM.
AND WHILE YOU'RE DOING
YOUR THING,
I'D LIKE TO TALK TO YOU A BIT
ABOUT OUR THING--
MAKING DELICIOUS FOOD.
JUST LOOK
AT THESE FINE DISHES.
YOU CAN ALMOST SMELL
THE QUALITY FOOD,
MADE FROM THE FINEST
INGREDIENTS AVAILABLE,
LIKE OUR FAMOUS
PASTRAMI SANDWICH,
FRESH COBB SALAD,
OR OUR RICH HOMEMADE CHILI.
MM-MM, LOOK AT THAT CHILI.
PEOPLE COME
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
TO EAT AT BILLY'S.
SO WHY NOT STICK AROUND
FOR A MINUTE?
YOU'LL BE GLAD YOU DID.
- BILLY'S DELI,
YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD TOILET.
- NOW I NEEDED TO SEE
IF THE COMMERCIAL
DID ITS JOB.
ARE YOU HUNGRY?
- UH, A LITTLE BIT.
- SO WE HAVE A FULL MENU.
- YEAH.
- YOU CAN LOOK AT THAT.
ALSO, UH,
WE NEED YOU TO SIGN, UH,
IF YOU WOULD,
A-AN APPEARANCE RELEASE.
WE WERE FILMING YOU
IN THE BATHROOM
WITH A HIDDEN CAMERA...
- OH, REALLY?
- TO SHOW
THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE.
- WHICH PART OF ME
WAS BEING FILMED?
- JUST YOU
WATCHING THE VIDEO.
- OH, OKAY,
BECAUSE I'M USING THE RESTROOM.
SO I'M WONDERING
WHAT PART OF IT--
- YEAH, YOUR PRIVATE PARTS
WON'T BE SHOWN.
- OH, OKAY.
- YOU SHOULD HAVE TOLD ME
THAT YOU GUYS
ARE GOING TO FILM.
YOU DIDN'T.
NOW YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
DELETE THIS THING.
AND I DON'T CARE
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO USE.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND THAT?
- THE IMPORTANT THING IS--
I JUST WANT TO KNOW--
- THAT'S THE IMPORTANT THING
FOR ME.
- WHAT ARE YOU GONNA EAT
TODAY AT BILLY'S, BECAUSE--
- AND IT'S A--
YOU'RE PLAYING
REALLY A DANGEROUS GAME
RIGHT NOW.
- OKAY, I'M SORRY.
WE WERE FILMING YOU
WHILE YOU WERE USING
THE BATHROOM.
- OH, OKAY.
- SO WE NEED TO, UH,
GET YOU TO SIGN
THIS RELEASE SO WE CAN USE
THE FOOTAGE
ON NATIONAL TELEVISION.
- OH.
- IF THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU.
- SURE.
- IS THAT OKAY?
- OKAY, YEAH, SURE.
- OKAY, THANKS SO MUCH.
I MEAN, IT BASICALLY SAYS
WE CAN DO ANYTHING WE WANT
WITH THE FOOTAGE
AND USE IT FOR ANYTHING.
- OH, OKAY, RIGHT.
- OKAY.
FOR THE MOST PART,